what is that generational difference
well back in june we saw the
announcement of ratchet and clank rift
apart from insomniac games
a title which uses the power of
playstation 5
the ssd hard drive and the dual sense
controller to create an experience that
insomniac says
is only possible on brand new hardware
well
now it's time for you to decide if you
see the difference here's an extended
uninterrupted demo of live playstation 5
gameplay
of ratchet and clank rift apart enjoy
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Applause]
and not far from where we last saw him
we may still have time to put a stop to
this
oh dear
bringing out the big guns
[Music]
feels good to be back in action
last one
the train's pulling away let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
i've been looking everywhere for you
put down the dimensionator nefarious
yeah right today i will finally be free
of the food for you
soon everything you see will be
mine
say goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
what
was that supposed to happen hitting
nefarious device seems to have
destabilized reality
the bridge is shot there has to be
another way across
hmm the rips appeared to react to your
device
try pointing it at one of them
that was rather exciting
uh
oh
this is worse than i had imagined
it's ratchet and clank
sand sharks from above
my heroes
[Music]
or at least a very large octopus
i will never get used to that hey at
least we're on the same planet this time
nefarious is on the other side of that
building let's get moving before he does
anything else to break reality
did dr nefarious really resurface after
all these
again yeah i kind of wish he was doing a
worse
job he must have more planned than he is
telling us
that's what i'm afraid of
wow
can't wait to see what's new
more butts
that's all of them we have to get the
dimensionator away from nefarious
the dimensions are weakening
considerably
[Music]
well it is certainly not good right
hello
[Music]
um
ratchet we are too late
ratchet
[Music]
who
there you have it ratchet and clank rift
apart and now i am joined by marcus
smith and mike daly from insomniac games
uh guys it was so great to see that uh
long uninterrupted demo of uh rift apart
and i have so many questions
uh it's amazing to see what you're doing
with the power of ps5 and the ssd
um let me ask you first marcus what are
you able to do with rift apart that you
haven't been able to do before in a
ratchet game because of the power of ps5
i mean first and foremost it's just pure
horsepower enables us to fill our worlds
with
the kind of density and life that we've
never been able to do before
more importantly perhaps though is the
dimensional shifting that we have going
on
which uses the ssd that allows us to
fling
the player from planet to planet to
planet uh
lightning fast like in way way faster
than we've ever been able to do before
yeah the the rift tether we saw that in
the demo we had seen some of that in the
the trailer so that's that's all actual
gameplay through the game are there
certain moments and levels where you can
jump or how do you play through that
yeah so in the game there is dimensional
damage spread throughout the galaxy that
ratchet and clank have to find a way to
fix
and you can find these weak points in
space-time
that you can pull to you with your rift
tether
it's like being able to lasso a portal
and that enables you to basically like
warp across the world
to find new places to discover or gain a
tactical advantage in combat
wow yeah i gotta say like when you see
that and you imagine the jumping from
multiple worlds
uh at at you know at instantaneously
almost and it sounds like there's no
load screens throughout the entire game
that's right we're going straight that's
right yep wow all right you bite so
confident both of you say it i like it
um now let me ask you about dual sense
that's something that is a big part of
ps5
i've had a chance to control with the
triggers and the haptics
um how are you using that to sort of
impact the gameplay of rift apart
so every ratchet and clank game is a
powerful arsenal
of weapons just exude a ton of
personality
and the dual sense is sort of like it
feels like it was made
for ratchet and clank just because the
haptics give us a whole new layer for
the weapons to express themselves
so for example your burst pistol of
course it gives you like a satisfying
click
or kick with every bullet but when you
throw the shatter bomb
you can actually feel the energy pulsing
off the grenade fade away as it gets
further apart from you
basically the haptics are expressive
enough that every weapon feels different
and you can tell what you're holding
but of course the adaptive trigger like
takes that to a functional level where
in addition to the trigger pull feeling
unique we can actually use that as a
super intuitive way
to add alternate functions to the
weapons so
for example in the demo we've got the
enforcer which is a double-barreled
shotgun
you can pull the trigger part of the way
down until you hit resistance
to fire a single barrel and then
whenever you feel like it's the right
time pull it the rest of the way for a
double shot
so you might be swarmed by a bunch of
little enemies you only want to
waste one shot on them and then wait a
minute for even more to swarm in before
finishing them off
but a big guy you probably want to just
give both barrels to you right away
so there's a nice intuitive way of
basically raising the skill ceiling
and giving you more ways to play better
wow no i'm
excited to see how you guys are gonna
roll that out across what i'm sure
are an insane uh you know group of
weapons as always uh
plot wise marcus tell us a bit about
this game i think some fans have
wondered you know
does this tie into the movie plot line
the game plot line like how it would
tell us in the ratchet verse where this
sits
yeah well canonically this is a an
extension of
uh ratchet and clank into the nexus the
2013 game
but it's a standalone adventure so it's
one that
even if you've never played a ratchet
and clank game you can get into it and
you'll understand it and you'll enjoy it
um for hardcore fans we have a lot of
nods you're gonna
you're gonna see a lot of returning
characters and planets and
uh see them all through a whole new
light of uh multiple dimensionality
yeah no this this rift tether thing i
think looks really exciting and how
often
like is that something we saw in the
demo is that something you're gonna see
like frequently in the game are there
special moments like i guess i'm curious
like how often you use that technique
for game play
so the the rift tether has created
these anomalies all throughout the
galaxy you'll encounter those pretty
often
there's even a few more types of
dimensional damage you'll encounter that
we haven't shown yet
now being pulled between worlds that's
that's localized to
chasing after dr nefarious in the demo
and that's sort of reserved for special
moments when you really have to
um when the dimensional damage really
tears wide open
well i gotta say it looks incredible and
then at the end
we got another tease of uh this female
lombax uh i know you guys are confirmed
she is playable
in parts of the game i think everyone
wants to know though do we have a name
for her
i mean the world is more interesting
with mysteries and we're gonna have to
keep this one
a little longer do we get a number of
letters in her name or anything
too many smart people on the internet
they'll figure it out right away she's
not named abby though right
all right we'll have to wait and see
what you guys have in store for us
i got to say i mean it looks incredible
the ratchet games are always so much fun
and as you said when you think of
the power of ssd and the dual sense all
coming together uh it looks really
exciting
before we go though uh i think everyone
around the world wants to know
when we're gonna get to play this game
anything you can share with us on where
you're at in development right now
right mike
sriracha and clank is coming out in the
ps5
launch window so we haven't announced a
release a specific release date yet so
stay tuned for that
what kind of window is it big window so
no i'm just kidding all right that's all
we're gonna get i'm sure
ratchet and clank rift apart coming in
the launch window for playstation five i
gotta say uh insomniac
uh we're so excited what you guys are
doing across playstation
and uh the game looks incredible so
thank you so much for
all you've done and we look forward to
seeing more of rift apart soon
thanks jeff take care all right marcus
and mike from insomniac
thanks for showing us that first look at
ratchet and clank or playstation live
and that's going to do it
for opening night live